fyi this story just came in if you want
to show it on what just happened
ukraine and the russia foreign minister
met together i don't know if you guys
saw that video
uh they had talks together nothing there
is no peace treaty nothing came out of
it ukraine four minutes it says russian
officials
live in their own reality after talks
fail if you want to go up so i can read
this talks between russian ukraine
foreign minister and turkey on thursday
ended in failure the discussions between
larov and kuleba lasted just an hour to
have ukraine foreign minister
comments come after russia's foreign
minister earlier denied that russian
forces had targeted civilians by bombing
the children's hospital and maternity
award on wednesday so
here's a good here's a bat what's the
good at least they faced off and they
had a meeting which is good okay
there is some progress going on okay
just the fact that they're willing to do
that i feel it's progress negotiation
sometimes you don't get it done the
first time or the second time around but
they were able to get together
does this mean it's over and putin's
going to say okay guys let's just kind
of don't worry about it it's okay i'm
over it that's we know that's not the
kind of guy he is he's going to continue
but uh i don't know i don't know what
with all the stuff that's going on right
now at what level are we gonna see this
slowing down all i know is i'm a little
bit more hopeful than i was two days ago
with the fact that these guys had to sit
down what do you think yeah there's a
really interesting article that is out
on the federalists about war games there
are over a hundred times in the last 10
years there have been simulations of
what happens when russia invades ukraine
does this draw in the united states does
this draw in nato does this result in
nuclear war and this guy was a part of
it he was a part of these war games and
he said every single time it resulted in
nuclear war because when putin feels
boxed in when he feels that his country
or himself when he feels mortally
threatened he unleashes a nuclear weapon
and this this article to me was really
eye-opening i actually like pondered it
it was in my mind for like two or three
days because i had been a little more on
the while zalenski is really courageous
he's staying there he's staying in his
office the people are being like the
resistance is amazing the propaganda i
forgive him for because that's that's
just that's the new kind of war right
and it made me actually rethink my view
on
zielinski's strategy and how it's
agitating the world and the reason i use
the word agitating is because i had used
the word rowling he's rallying the world
behind you know behind his cause on
behalf of the ukrainian people against
putin who's obviously evil and doing a
bad thing and i after i read this
article i thought actually what he's
doing is he's agitating the world
because and the reason for that is
because he wants people meaning voters
us america specifically and europe he
wants the people to have an emotional
connection to the ukrainian people so
that we pressure our lawmakers to give
him what he needs but if you read this
federalist piece and it it it talks
about what specifically tips putin over
the edge to a nuclear war you know just
the slightest like a no-fly zone tips
putin over into a nuclear war um certain
weapons tip putin over into a nuclear
war because he doesn't want to be struck
first and it made me think the united
states should be very very careful we
obviously should condemn putin of course
he's evil and he shouldn't be doing what
he's doing but we should be very very
cautious and very skeptical of what
zolensky the operation that he is waging
against us or trying to get our approval
because things as simple as
words or those jeffs that's putin or
yeah offends putin to the point that he
feels mortally threatened and i was very
encouraged i actually think zalenski
should consider the deal that the
kremlin offered him they offered him
they said you know acknowledge that
crimea is russian and acknowledge that
these separatist regions are independent
and um put in your constitution that you
won't you won't get into nato or the eu
and you know this will he the words from
the kremlin word this will all stop in a
minute if i were zolensky i'd seriously
consider that well it sounds like he is
i think he had a couple comments that
that basically he's not
interested in joining nato what's the
quote that he said yeah that was that
was just yesterday i think
he was cooled
he's cooled on that and and they're open
to those regions you know from
russian-backed separatists rejoining the
russian federation what have you
um
but
you gotta hand it to the guy man i mean
the world is rallying around this guy
and and i think it's only going to get
worse for the russian economy i think
they're going to default on uh on their
loans what's that story if you want to
cover that oregon stanley well just just
real quick uh we got a pretty good
interesting comment in here and a lot of
people echo this it's from a guy named
critic geek and adam it's all officially
your fault
i just wanted to let you know it's all
adam's why does tyler have a mic
sometimes
makes a lot of sense i mean it does
point back to one person it's not adam
but it points back to biden i mean this
could all have been avoided none of this
had happened that's why i that's why i
recommend to stilenski that he consider
this it's not because it's a good deal
it's not no one wants to give up part of
their self-determination their autonomy
or their democracy but it's because
we're in this lose-lose situation the
binary options both are terrible um and
the reason we're in that binary choice
is because of decisions made by joe
biden
what should biden have done differently
in regards to this he should have
continued the sanctions on the nordstrom
2 pipeline that's probably the single
thing that could have prevented this the
most he also also should have
not been relying on russian oil he
should have continued our the united
states path towards energy independence
um those two things i mean that's really
the leverage that putin has those two
things putin cares about his profit he
cares about his pocketbook just like
everybody does and if you threaten that
that's also that's also his leverage for
controlling the response from european
nations so biden really just could have
done those those two or three things and
this could have been prevented
so the morgan stanley story we're
talking about is a fortune story says
russia could default as soon as next
month morgan stanley says russia's
economy is so weak that it may have to
default on its foreign debt soon with
analysts comparing it to venezuela in a
note on monday
simon waver morgan stanley's global head
of emergency market sovereign credit
strategy warned that russia's economy
was inching
perilously
close to default territory as the west
imposes sanctions and talks of a
recession mount we see a default as most
likely scenario
waiver said predicting that the default
may occur on as early as april 15 a date
that will mark the end of 30-day grace
period on coupon payments that the
russian government owes on dollar bonds
in case of default it is unlikely to be
a normal one with venezuela instead
perhaps the most relevant comparison
what does the default do to russia i
mean he just the guy the guy's making a
threat saying i'll take it up to 300
instead of what it is today you want to
do a default with us they're just going
to make 40 percent of you still relying
on these guys with gas do you really
think this default is real threat to
russia
no i don't think so either no the
sanctions go one way not i'm not going
to pay you next month that it doesn't
work it doesn't work that way you know i
read a very interesting book called you
know the next czar
and it's a story about putin and it's
very very interesting when you read
about it you read about where he went up
and where his education was and and one
of the things is
he is employing bizarre thinking and
part of the czar thinking is you know
military imperialism and rebuilt and
rebuilding but the other part of bizarre
thinking is zero endgame
i mean the czars were literally
unafraid of
you know
of of their own mortality or fatality
and and that is the character flaw that
was in the czars and so when i read this
and what you talk about but you're just
talking about just now liz i mean it
lines up you know beware the guy that
really isn't concerned about the end
game the way you think of an end game
yeah but at what point does putin like
were saying that it's biden's fault okay
maybe there's parts of it that it is but
at what point does putin have to accept
responsibility that attacking ukraine
and invading ukraine is basically
crumbling
and dismantling the russian economy what
uh inflation has reached double digits
by far interest rates are 20 percent at
this point the ruble is crumbling is
worth a penny you can't use your
mastercard atm i'm our visa
amex
the stores are closing there's sanctions
galore i mean at the end of the day is
it all worth it so you can take back
parts of russia that are you know
russian-backed uh and speak russian at
what point does putin have to say you
know what
this isn't actually a good idea to do
all this you're applying western thought
of good bad that's not how he's thinking
i'm sorry i i mean is western is your
economy crumbling and your and your
ruble crumbling a western philosophy he
i don't think he's worried about it how
can you not
well if you're not if you're not
accountable to your people i mean right
that's the problem with dictators and
authoritarian is when things are going
badly for the people the people don't
have the power to say well we're going
to vote you out of office we're going to
hold you accountable when someone's an
authoritarian they're going to live high
on the hog and it doesn't really matter
if the people suffer i actually had a
really interesting conversation with
senator ted cruz i co-host that new
series the cloak room with him on
verdict plus and i asked him about
putin's mental state because there's
been some insinuations from people like
senator marco rubio or even condoleezza
rice she was on the view and she said
listen i i interacted with putin five or
six times in person and he's a killer
he's evil but he's a rational actor as
defined in foreign policy meaning not a
jihadist not a death wish she's a
rational actor but she said recently his
behavior seems to be more erratic it
doesn't seem to be in that same vein and
so i this
obviously they didn't go into this much
deeper on the view and i thought wow we
really should be talking about that
exact comment and so i asked senator
cruz i was like listen i have access to
a lot of open source information you
have access to a lot of classified
information what's the what's the
psychoanalysis of vladimir putin is he
still acting as a rational actor and i
mean obviously he can't he can't
disclose super classified information
but he said as far as he can tell as far
as he's seen putin is still acting as a
rational actor if you understand what
his ideology is which should inform the
world it should inform the world what
are how we react and these sanctions i
mean these sanctions
understand who they hurt the most too
they hurt not just the people they hurt
the oligarchs and the oligarchs there
control putin they're very influential
so you're saying that they control putin
yeah yeah the oligarchs he needs the
support of the oligarchs but then that
goes to your point though what you said
yesterday
so that good meaning you what does he
listen to
yeah so you can't lose them if they lose
their minds you saw what happened with
the soccer thing the other day yesterday
the
britain roman chelsea romana abramovic
babies owner of the nets too had to sell
the nets and the barclays arena uh he
was a russian because he had tied to
vladimir putin yeah he sold that five
years ago that wasn't recently that was
years ago but now i mean think about
what's happening to them right now i
mean their yachts are their yachts are
being sunk they can't go the riviera
they can't send their children to elite
universities around the globe i mean
they
yeah roman obama that started to cut you
off was actually sanctioned this morning
and now he can't sell the club for the
three billion
pounds he wanted to sell it for
so my point initially was i hope it's
all worth it vladimir yeah i hope all
this is worth getting crimea
that
you know you're losing support in your
country you're losing support from the
oligarchs your people are standing in
bread lines atm lines the ruble's worth
nothing but hey
you got a little more territory i think
i think the whole thing the strategy is
what outwork out improve out strategize
but what's the last one outlast this is
a lasting game right now this is all a
stamina and fatigue game right now now
do you think this actually helps him
out last or does this diminish his
chances of outlawing no no i think if
kremlin is making the request on what
they want i think
he is waiting for zielinski to burn out
and fatigue and say okay fine we'll make
it work look what happened with
pashinian from armenia eventually he
says okay let's get down let's sit down
and talk and they sat down with
azerbaijan and putin and figured out a
way to do it right that happened very
quickly not very quickly it was about a
month
i mean it didn't take months and months
and months and months
but but you're telling us we still got a
couple weeks left till april 15 default
so this this guy has a timeline in his
mind he's thinking i'm gonna go till
this day like this is not a meeting it's
like what do they say go this is a
meeting of
40 moves ahead of what we're gonna if
this guy says this this is the plan if
that guy says this this is the plan if
that guy says start this press this send
this guy to call send this call the
media on this shut this thing down of me
they this is this is a
months and months maybe a year's
strategy of what to do in this moment
that's all it is i don't think they're
winning a default is basically when you
just don't make your payments right
i think he has a time in his head does
do you think that's my question do you
think he's actually concerned about this
april 15th deadline i don't think that's
ironically attacking i'm just given the
date that morgan stanley gives i just
think he has a date on the default date
i'm saying is do you think he's
concerned about no he don't that's not
that if they go back to communism the
people in that country is like what are
you talking about just 30 years ago the
communism what do you guys complaining
about
but but i'm saying this that he's
thinking this i'm not saying it as i'm
saying it that's how he processes that
you know what international women's day
he said hey on international women's day
this is a great opportunity for us to
recognize our men that are at war
this is this mentality
so if you enjoyed this little segment
from the podcast click over here to
watch the entire podcast and if you've
not subscribed to the channel please do
so take care everybody
[Music]
you